VERA KOPP: inCast is a
crowdsourcing platform
to connect entertainment
professionals.
It's a place where producers
can post notices and look
for talent and talent can
look for opportunities.
Building a marketing plan
for me wasn't so difficult
since I'm in the industry.
I have a lot of
connections with producers,
big production
companies in Brazil,
as well as broadcasters.
I have produced
content in Hollywood
and sold it to Brazil.
So I think, mainly, your
roots and your network
is step number one for marketing
and acquisition of clients.
I know for sure that
a lot of those people
will be my testing sample.
And I will absorb every
single information from them
to, you know, change inCast
and customize to their needs.
I think that's very important.
Adjusting the product
to your demographic.
I think a great
example of, you know,
getting the feedback
from this experience
is just as simple as
that main landing page.
We were trying to convey our
company message versus focusing
on our mission and the
problem that we're solving.
So we didn't have too much
call to action buttons.
And people can't
guess where they are
and what they're doing.
I think that the experience has
to be, like, a little bit more
seamless.
So putting bigger buttons
and conveying your message
a little bit more
clearer, that's
what I'm ready to do right now.